oh okay God wake up one oh just don't
want to see your legs up in like that
okay
there was what out oh maybe more than
one we have like really short short side
you're just my junk is will you flash
the camera why but cut it out remember
you were in the dress exam for it so
anyway all right so really sweet hurt
really
so this is wake up alright so this is
kind of a continuation from the the last
episode where Jake's partying with
prismo in his crib and there's all these
uh I don't you would call it just sort
of paranormal entities or people have
dealt with the dark arts that I can't
explain just cosmic and paranormal
people and just hanging out and partying
pretty much God's magical for the most
part good it's peppermint Butler he's
dabbled
he's like best friends with death though
because you have death yeah we was doing
like the black magic stuff yeah the
party god you have the four gods
Grob glob you know those and the Lich
but the Lich is there for a different
reason
oh yeah I love those setups and yeah I
love those setups where like you have a
world that's so big and you source you
introduce all these characters at one
point you take the ones I have like one
thing in common then they all get
together for yep they're like when all
the wizards got together I love that
kind of stuff I love Zima just party and
hang out and stuff that kind of stuff I
always think
great um so yeah so they go and they're
just partying everything and Finn is
still thinking about well how can I can
i with my father and stuff so Jake takes
into prismo and they figure out that the
Citadel is a prison which Finn thinks
like maybe the father is the warden but
I'm thinking some prisoner okay I don't
know that's just my guess but so they
had so they had to figure out how to get
there I tell it if he makes the guess
it's always gonna be like the opposite
what is usually well maybe he's this
it's gonna be the opposite usually so
that's my guess I could be wrong maybe
I'll surprise me be exactly what they
say it is it'd be weird surprise but
still so they have to go and yeah kitty
okay no kitties meow okay so so he goes
and they had to wake up this old man
they don't know why they just know it's
part of getting them to the Citadel and
so they go he's releasing out all these
evil spirits and they zap him to get him
back and turns out the old man sleeping
is actually prismo and once he wakes up
prismo will not be because he's actually
an old man's dream neat idea um and so
they're about to wake him up and then
suddenly the Lich comes in he was
actually alive and listening the whole
time which I thought was a great a
legitimately great scare yes cuz he's
just been standing there the whole time
and they've established he can't hear
anything you can do whatever you want
and then just suddenly just him go like
that it was just like a whoa like it was
a real creepy moment um so he grabs him
wakes him up kills the guy and he gets
sent to the Citadel for doing that and I
think Finn is going toward or it's gonna
get there as well he says I'm coming dad
and then it cuts it's the first week out
we don't see if he actually makes it in
there but see how the next one called
escape from the Citadel yeah my guess is
he made it um so yeah it's uh I think
it's a pretty solid start I think it's a
good mix again a sort of like just
typical adventure time just characters
hanging out you know being themselves
kind of a
quest of not waking this guy up more
Jake yeah you know thank God I was
really missing him I was missing the
visual that she could do with him too
like we formed it to a bed yeah just
that yeah I miss how they used to work
off each I love how we just got it first
music you know just like wake up old man
it's like just don't wake him up then he
goes to the tiny little keyhole and
that's like man that'd be so awesome
yeah it's like what would I really
realize how much I make there but yeah
um so yeah I yeah I thought it's good
but then you got more of the story with
you know the Lich coming to life again
and like is it just a great scare with
that looking up and yeah it looks like
some sort of story is getting going now
they're obviously gonna go with us at
the del we're gonna see what's there and
uh yeah I liked oh my god yes yes yes
yes yes I had never been so invested in
characters and and it just I hate to
bring it back to lemonhope but it just
goes to show though if you have you know
for two full episodes that's been
dragged out on my own and give a crap
you know prismo you know was in that one
episode one and a half Article III well
technically he was part of the Lich
episode part of in in the human and part
of Jake the dog he was kind of he just
kind of been there a little bit guys you
get to and I just just seeing him on
screen when he first popped up I'm
already yelling I'm like oh my god I
love him and then and then you see
everybody and I just kept getting more
and more excited like cosmic al I don't
know anything about him he's just the
cosmic owl but still I care more and it
was like oh my god yay and it just meant
so much more I mean all these things
were happening and you're absolutely
right with the Lich it was like oh my
god oh no oh my gosh I just that's about
what I did the whole episode I think is
go oh yay and also oh my god um but it's
good that's how good it was is that I
was so invested and so involved and
everything that was happening I just you
know couldn't stop and it was this I
mean I really was kind of distraught it
was like oh my god what are you gonna do
you have to kill prismo in order to get
to your dad but is your dad I mean it
feels like I don't know if it's worth
seeing my dad you know and and that
prismo is even saying like dude it's
alright
you know just kill me it's alright I
mean it you know if you want to see I
don't know it's it's a lot it's a lot in
a good way it's a lot emotionally in a
very very good way a mage's that's yeah
and why is the Lich want to be captured
too yeah that's an interesting question
that is a huge question and I wonder if
it has to do with well maybe not I was
at first I thought it might have
something to do with Finn's dad but
really prismo was saying though like oh
well you know he's meant to destroy a
life but as long as he's in my little
box he can't so he's at a standstill so
maybe it didn't matter if it was the
city that was not okay yeah clearly he
did I mean clearly he killed the guys so
yeah that's true but well he was only
able to kill him after he woke them up
was that rule you can only kill people
when they were asleep ahead I didn't
know cuz remember it's like he hurt and
he said well you know because if he was
gonna kill prismo he would have killed
the old man right then and there but
remember he didn't he shook him and he
said wake up wake up wake up he woke him
up before he killed him so I wonder if
it had something to do with just prismo
being there and being you know in this
special box or whatever that once prismo
was gone from the box then he could do
whatever he wanted
whatever it was is all great hojae I saw
huh um I I think it was it's as long as
prismo exists in his prismo form the
Lich can't escape he can't get out and
upon killing human prismo or waking up
prismo he's able to finally escape or
kill again or whatever because by
killing him The Citadel happens all that
stuff yada yada yada
um no I I really liked this episode I
thought it was fun yeah that's hard to
say it's fun no I mean see you know man
die like when he what are you saying
okay go pick up the old man and you get
there and oh my god that's principal
look I kind of figured it out I don't
want that together yeah I'd totally been
really good but for me it didn't take
anything away because when they got back
I love how he's like no no it's okay you
know finally go back to bed and all that
stuff and Finn's like but wait a minute
is it's worth it let go for it and
you're not like so angry at that bucket
but I love how he's like he's like whoa
let me take one quick look around and he
looks he's like man if I don't have more
stuff yeah my only real I mean I liked
everything about it was it was a fun
good episode
prismo dying that shocked the heck out
of me like I I saw okay the cosmic
prismo dying but did not see the Lich
just disintegrated you know the human
principal that was like whoa what the
hell you know drive around a good point
lemonhope let me know it wasn't just as
many episodes pretty much I think maybe
one less then prismo but like prismo
just the way Jake talks about prismo
prismo when I'm around you you make me
smile I don't know what it is you're
always making me laugh you know and all
that stuff it's like that's cool I know
one prismo dies just how pissed Jake got
like it wasn't just like you was upset
No
he was pissed I like how they just
immediately re-establish that dread with
the Lich again I mean it's one thing is
like because I mean last time we saw him
yeah it's like he he was wearing the
skin of his hero he's still wearing the
skin yeah you know that's gotta be
pretty creepy for Finn to see I really
thought when he gave me just a Billy
Billy or something again but um and yeah
just like as soon as he's awake it's
like he kills off another character it's
just like oh I think there is serve like
like itself when he moved his head I did
legitimately just my heart kind of
dropped like oh no I'm afraid to of
course like I kind of know it's coming I
mean they're building it up but I don't
know when how I thought they'd be a
little bit more explanation or something
like yeah I guess I thought that was
such a good payoff oh yeah
Miley I guess problem if anything for
the most part is last episode again I
don't know how we never know how much
time passes in between each episode you
know could be day it could be a week
could be a month who knows but last
episode Finn or Jake didn't even
acknowledge that Billy was dead
remember that nope he is not there yet
he's not ready he's not prepared Jake
still felt that Billy was alive and
maybe enough time passed I don't know or
maybe it's because half the face is gone
it's the Lich and nut but he's looking
at Billy skin that whole time and he's
not like I don't know it just seemed a
really good point and it annoyed me a
bit because it was like it felt like
they just didn't want Jake to be in last
episode yeah honestly that's most like
so yeah so they needed some kind of
excuse which I thought was a good excuse
like it was a really good one but this
one it was just like I don't know you
know and then of course you having Jake
going oh don't worry about the Lich no
big deal blah blah blah it's like I
don't know that just seems a little
awkward a little off you know it could
still be part of
you could argue like he doesn't even see
Billy skid-man because it's like
partially torn he sees cement Ilych and
not as Billy yeah yeah I'll go with you
though I'd still be like I don't know I
I'd imagine you have a little bit more
of a problem or so then clearly not too
much time could have passed by because
you know if Finn would not have been
that bad for so long before Jake
discovers him and emits you know I was
told where my father is
yeah but not chances are they just
mistake yeah I guess um the other thing
that I then I was kind of weirded out by
was death seemed to be afraid of the
Lich I can't like that though hey it was
interesting I'm like dude your death but
then again that kind of puts the
emphasis on how nasty the Lich yeah but
then again at the same token we're
hearing about the Citadel were the worst
of the worst of the worst of the worst
go to so why wasn't the Lich already
there maybe you didn't get to that point
of being able to kill off everything
yeah well you have to you could only go
there if you committed a cosmic oh
that's right no your idea
so maybe of all the primes it still
wasn't yes I got that yeah yeah maybe
that's his goal to get to the Citadel
like just so he could be like one of the
great criminals or something like that I
don't know probably not or maybe kill
off all the criminals in there shall we
find out in the next episode
no yes we're done for this whole week
very good sure do the next episode Lisa
didn't do the flashy thing now you're
going to you're right